foi pra você que não me conhece meu nome
é lucas lira esse é meu canal o invento
na hora não é esse
esse canal é é não faltou uma faca e aí
a turma vocês como está todo acho que
está tudo bem tudo tranquilo da tuna no
windows xp em dia tenho viajado muito
assim acho que desde o último andar
porque eu fui em aracaju que eu até
ganhei presente aqui o presente caso não
para em caso de viagem direto não para
não para não para não para o caso de
minha casa toda bagunçada
não na verdade não tem nada de verdade
ela sentava no chão e eu fiquei esse dia
todo está muito cansado muito cansado e
quando viaja não tenho costume de dormir
no ônibus domingo haviam dúvidas e foi
arrastada acordado que eu tenho medo de
morrer domingo imagina que padece de
morrer dormindo donato aparece no lugar
de que a mesma era um macho morreu é o
mundo só que esse idiota alto cansando
tão cansado de viajar que eu dormi um
que o que aconteceu se sabe quando a
gente dorme há gente no estado de
identificação que a gente acorda mesmo
quem sabe o que está acontecendo entre a
carne ficar por dentro do olho
procurando muito a perguntar se ela
tinha feito a comida a domingo o meu
lado e pôr assim que três anos roda
rodoviário de teresina e toda vez que eu
vou viajar ele me pede dinheiro dizendo
que vai completar a passagem de volta
para casa de mãos a comida bem r$5 etapa
completar passar meus filhos minha
esposa na cidade lá nunca mais vestirá
em comissão da assembléia vamos botar
passagem eu dou 53 anos que ele me pede
para 3 mp dinheiro à conta da passagem
do carro só pode tá mora na disney é
engraçado pelo delegado aydes fácil da
ema em bens autorizando o velho jogo de
volta no assunto e domingo eu parei pra
pensar sobre onde ficou engraçado que
quando cai o dólar
engraçado manda sou eu acho engraçado
dormir é o jeito diferente do que a
televisão ela morre o jeito que a gente
dorme de um jeito bonito gente for fun e
um jeito singelo de um jeito em um jeito
totalmente preparar se tomava é que não
é desse jeito não é assim que o dono se
por exemplo se uma pessoa assim
bom dia mundo bom dia natureza dia todos
na vida real a gente agora é assim quer
dizer nessa botão bonita que a televisão
mostra também atacou muito estranho
quando é o seguinte quando a gente aqui
ao nosso lado aqueles sons indigitar
vontade de dormir na votação sony time
de dono de tarde e acorda pensando que
há outro dia eu estava três horas quase
cinco horas da tarde na volta procurando
café é procurando cuscuz e liga a
televisão a programação levam toda a
madrugada parece você dormiu até giro 15
vez em quando cai a fifa vai bancar a
ficha ainda não é outro dia você fica
naquela tarde já sabia já que graças a
deus todo mundo é o seguinte a que
recebe o duque eu desperto em alguma
hora do domínio de espera é o eps e lá
eu vejo que eu posso dormir mais um
pouco aí eu digo assim aquela famosa
frase não só mais cinco no time nesses
cinco minutinhos paz que deus ram também
é tomada aqui a não admissão mais cinco
minutinhos a dormir aqui de macho nesses
cinco minutos e eu do qual é a copa do
brasil ganhou a copa lançar o iphone 9 e
jacó com crianças batem em papai papai
levanto me leva a escola passa uma vida
e do mesmo todo mundo gosta de dormir
dormir é muito bom mas tem um inimigo
dormir só tem um inimigo sono ele só tem
um imortal da vida desses aí você vai
dizer que agora sabe que é um imortal do
sono
a mãe da gente tendo o céu 71 anos o que
tem na minha mãe não
meu deus a minha mãe minha corda para eu
arrumar a cama e não arruma a cama
depois o dono de novo
a lista está também sem fio pen drive de
16 gb de sono e você chega à sua mãe
para arrumar o quarto a mãe ela é ninja
ela varria a casa limpa a casa 50 ano
ela no disco novo não é quanto tá
dormindo em papel a4 parece assim uma
cidade de caibí button vai lá para baixo
e back office boy na suzana vamos top
box do banheiro de casa quando desgraça
a gente mas pra mim não tem coisa pior
não tem coisa pior para estragar o meu
som do que isso eu vou mostrar pra vocês
agora to do
a copel já marquei não pertençam
i que é
o im que é mãe de will i am que é ruim
mãe é mãe
oi williams ou um bairro mais do que me
ver com ódio é fazer um negócio desses
eu quero que você me conte comigo aqui
em baixo alguma coisa estranha que
aconteceu com você enquanto você dormia
o que você mais odeia que acontece
quando você está dormindo muito obrigado
a sentar se tivesse vindo até aqui não
se esquece você tiver gostar de ver se
divertir explica que gostei até a bainha
a barrinha aqui e gostei não gostei
desse pequeno junho para cima você me
ajuda demais nas redes sociais é que a
descrição do vídeo e quiserem seguir no
instagram no twitter no facebook
qualquer lugar tá aqui quer dizer para
você estar em brasília a dia 26 agora
pontos de venda dos ingressos está aqui
na descrição do vídeo também quando terá
insistido muito obrigado
um beijo no fígado de cada um